John.
We do have some police scanner audio.
So this is right before we're told that
the police beat Tyre Nichols.
So this is
then when I think they're first
pulling him over.
So let's listen to that.
We got one more black runs
from
this vehicle from overseas, right?
A relative of one running on the run,
it running as a twin as well.
So we don't care
if he's fighting a decent
object for that.
What do you hear there, John?
So I hear they've made the stop,
but we don't hear that part.
And then he's running
and then he comes on and says, run
that tag and see where it comes back to.
So he's gotten away
and they're trying to figure out,
well, if he's running home,
where is that?
Because it could be nearby.
And of course it is.
It's about half mile away.
And that's standard police stuff, right?
That's right.
I mean, that's
that's that's what they should be doing.
And then the next person you hear on
the air has caught up to him
and is fighting and calls out the street
that it's happening on, which is history.
He's about 80 yards from his home
and then he's calling for backup.
So there's a whole bunch of questions
that Shimon says,
you know, still need to be answered.
But let's go through a couple of them.
What was the stop for?
This is a missing piece.
They said reckless driving originally.
But what was the reckless driving?
No one's articulated that.
What was the first
altercation about that
resulted in him
being pepper sprayed and running away?
And then what was the second
altercation about?
All of these are still blanks.
And what we've been told
is that when the tape is released,
you're going to see the incident
from end to end
and some,
if not all, of these questions
will be answered.
Shimon,
one of the things
that the police were charged with
was aggravated kidnaping,
and that got people's attention
because what does that mean?
So, you know,
I know that you asked that question.
We were told that that meant that he was
sort of unlawfully detained
or contained somehow.
Do you have any more information on that?
Yeah, that was one of those charges
that really,
I think, caught many of us by surprise
because you certainly never see this
in these kinds of cases.
So we don't have any clarity.
The way the D.A.
explained it is
you may have had an initial proper stop
and they may or may have
that may have been legal, let's say.
And then as you go through the
through this encounter
and then you go
into the second encounter,
then that is where
that may have occurred,
where was an illegal detainment
of some kind.
And because of the nature of this
and how this all unfolded,
and their aggravating circumstances,
that's why they charged this kidnap.
Remember, there are also
the allegations here
that the
victim here
was handcuffed
during this time
during some of this beating.
Certainly, the D.A.
wouldn't talk about that.
And that is something
we will likely see in the video.
So that could pertain to that as well.
John, they're going to release
this video,
we're told, tomorrow night at 6 p.m..
That's a Friday night at 6 p.m..
Does that make sense to you? Does that.
Is that sort of ripe for trouble?
If this were in New York City
and I was in the NYPD, and this came up,
I would want this on a Tuesday,
a school night. A work night. Yeah.
But I think what you're seeing
in Memphis is
they have delivered
the beginning of justice.
They have brought extraordinarily
serious charges
and a slew of them against each officer.
They have arrested them.
And, you know, one of them has made bail.
Others are trying to raise bond,
but they are now in the system.
And I think
the way they are choreographing this is
let's make sure that people see
that justice is being done.
That's the beginning of it.
And then we'll release the tape,
because if they did them together,
I think justice would have been largely
drowned out by the shock over the tape.
I think they wanted people
to digest that.
The that the system is working
and then see the tape.
And then they have all day today.
They have tonight
and they have all day tomorrow up
until 5:00
when they're going to release six
I should clarify, 6 p.m.
local time in Memphis, 7 p.m.
7 p.m.
here to do that community outreach to say
if we're going to march,
let's march together.
If we're going to protest,
let's protest peacefully.
And I
think that Memphis
is confident
that they have a handle on this.
Now, Ali, the question is,
what does that mean in New York,
in Chicago, in L.A.,
where there are they prepared?
Well, they've been preparing.
And, you know,
I think they are waiting
and watching carefully
and I think they're all going to be
watching this tape.
John, thank you.
Shimon, thank you very much
for being on the ground for us.